>> BORT: You'll hear a lot about Android devices,
but that's just a small part of what Android
really is.
>> BORNSTEIN: When you think about a device
like an Android device, that's a gizmo, that's
a thing, you can go to the store, or you can
buy that.
>> BORT: There are tons of devices out there
on the shelf or whatever, and, you know, maybe
someday each one of those will be running
Android. You know, they all look different,
they all, you know, cost different, they could
be a bunch of different things that will be
made by different people, but, you know, one
of our goals would be just get Android all
over the place and we've done that in a bunch
of different ways mostly by making it so that's
really easy for the industry to adopt. We've
made it free. You don't have to license it.
We've done a lot of work making sure that
this platform is viable to the industry. Manufacturers
and carriers are more likely to adopt the
whole platform. And we make it easy for developers
to extend the platform to make sure that it
stays, you know, on the cutting edge of the
industry. In developing Android or developing
something like this, there's always this tension
between a product and a platform.
>> BORNSTEIN: A platform is what enables you
to make all of those things.
>> BORT: As we built the Android platform,
we've spend a lot of time thinking how about
it's going to be used in the future.
>> BORNSTEIN: There are several layers in
the Android system. It's a complete software
of stack.
>> BORT: We got the Linux Kernel, the system
libraries, Dalvik, the application framework,
and then all of the applications on top of
that.
>> BORNSTEIN: The Linux Kernel has been around
for many, many years. It's tried and true.
It's used in millions of computers and devices,
but it hasn't really been thoroughly optimized
for mobile devices. So what we did was we
worked on power management. We worked on a
new shared memory driver. We worked on this
thing we call the binder which is this Lightweight
IPC Mechanism. And we did work on--just on
the scheduler to really make it work efficiently
for a small device.
>> BORT: We pulled a lot of libraries in from
the Open Source community, big ones like WebKit
and Harmony, OpenSSL.
>> BORNSTEIN: The Apache HttpComponents and
ICU.
>> BORT: In addition to a lot of the other
open source libraries that Android uses, we're
open-sourcing a bunch of new libraries as
part of the Android platform.
>> BORNSTEIN: Among the things that we wrote
ourselves were a bunch of media codecs, so
for sound and video.
>> BORT: And we have Graphics Libraries.
>> BORNSTEIN: 2D and 3D graphics and Speech
Recognition.
>> BORT: Dalvik is a new virtual machine that
was designed by Dan that was intended to be
on these mobile devices.
>> BORNSTEIN: It was designed to deal well
in a memory-constrained and CPU-constrained
environment where you're operating off a battery
power.
>> BORT: The application framework makes it
easy for application developers to use all
the different pieces of a mobile device. You
know, you're going to have things like the
screen, maybe a touch screen, a track ball,
the buttons, a GPS.
>> BORNSTEIN: And, of course, the platform
really wouldn't be complete without some applications.
And so we've built them. We've included a
web browser, an email client, instant messaging,
a camera for the phone, a dialer, contacts,
and the list goes on.
>> BORT: At every layer of the platform, we
put in hooks to make it so that people can
extend it in ways that we never even thought
of. We partnered with kernel.org to host the
source, and we built tools to help developers
interact with the source. We're using git
as the source control system, but we built
a bunch of tools on top of it to make it a
lot easier to deal with the platform as large
as Android.
>> BORNSTEIN: We have a tool called Repo which
manages multiple git repositories and let's
people deal with them as a single unit. This
is super important for Android because, in
fact, we don't have just one source code repository.
We have about a hundred of them. We also have
a web-based tool called Gerrit. And this is
what we use for source code reviews and for
accepting patches and stuff like that. So
if a developer wants to submit a patch back
to the Android source code, they can use Gerrit,
they can submit their patch through it, and
then the developer who works on that particular
component will be able to see the code and
comment on it and write a review, and there
can be kind of a back and forth between the
main, say, like the lead for that component
and the person submitting the patch. Once
the patch looks good, you can just hit the
button and it gets checked in and then it
becomes part of the open source project.
>> BORT: The Android OpenSource Project is
ready for you to explore and contribute right
now at source.android.com.
>> BORNSTEIN: What will you do with Android?
>> BORT: What will you do with Android?